did you go to school for writing I went
to dabble Valley College which at the
time had a film appreciation class where
you watch movies and wrote book reports
on them and then once a semester you had
to make a three and a half minute short
film the reason why I was three and a
half minutes is because that's the
length of a super 8 film cartridge and
so most films were not edited most of
the students films were not edited I
handed in a 30 minute edited film that
was a parody of all of the movies we had
to watch during the semester it was
called the shorts of Bill Martel and it
opened up with my under the titles on my
underpants and then the opened up with a
Citizen Kane because you have to watch
Citizen Kane if you're in film
appreciation class and the guy Citizen
Kane dies and says see B DeMille and
then everybody has to figure out what CB
DeMille means and they're like going
through all this stuff and then it ends
up being each one of the reporters ends
up finding one of the parodying one of
the movies we had to see all the way
through from oh jeez what do we have to
see triumph of the will was in there
just like all the films they make you
watch in film class you know and I did
parodies of all of them and everybody
laughed at it and the student film night
they brought back the success stories
from Duyvil valley college to judge them
which Paul curiosity kung-fu guy was
there also a guy that made did all the
commercials for all of the used-car Lots
in the area and last but not least Jim
Mitchell from the Mitchell brothers porn
who had actually gone to dial-up Valley
College and their student films were
legendary and afterwards the guy that
did that used car commercial things come
with me hoes hey look man you know I
liked your movie and I need people to
lug my equipment you want to do that and
I said not really what I was thinking
about and then Jim Mitchell came up to
me and said hey you know we make we make
feature films they play in our thirty
five-millimeter in our cinemas we're
looking always looking for new talent
would you like to direct one of these
and I thought man what would my mom
think if I directed a porn film and
what's my mom doing watching porn films
and it kind of ruined me for a while and
then Paul came up he knows you know hey
that was pretty good and that was it and
he goes I'm getting ready to do this
movie and I need people to you know
pitch in and do stuff it's a kung fu
movie you know and I said cool and I
gave him a script at the time he read
the script and liked it and then I ended
up like current on his film for free and
that led to the screenwriting job which
led to nothing by the way after that but
that's you know well is there a Reader's
Digest version of the nut cheerios ha
the nothing ended up being that you know
after basically being the big fish in
the small pond and it was like a a real
estate guy who an erisa a company he was
like and he owned all this property and
he was like I basically want to make a
movie so that you know everyone has
their evil reasons you know so that I
can meet starlets and you know I'm
looking for a script that has to have a
lot of starlets in it so I pitched
stories to him we developed something I
had another guy who was they had
actually produced another drive-in movie
it was like in the area and I wrote a
script for him that never got off the
ground and some other stuff and then
basically because all of these things
never got off the ground it sort of I I
moved through my pond
and you know there was nothing left
there so I went back to work working at
Safeway in a warehouse and did that for
a period of time at the same time I was
writing every day I actually got some
options during that period of time
including when they got really close I
wrote a script called treasure hunter
that I had a meeting in Beverly Hills
with a producer on it was going to put
it together and at the time I had the
worst agent in the world and the my
terrible agent was like they were every
time they said well we don't have a lot
of money so we can't pay your writer a
lot of money my my agent would go that's
okay and like that's not okay you know
you're supposed to be fighting for me so
I ended up at one point telling the
producer that I was gonna leave and if
he ever wanted to make a serious offer
he could call me but I'm out of here and
got up and walked down the street and as
I was walking down whatever the street
it was in Beverly Hills the big fat
producer comes out and he's like chasing
me down the street and
to come back and made a good offer and
then they never made the movie but you
know was it I actually made it was an
option of like $6,000 off that which was
you know I was working full-time it was
great to get a little extra money and it
was also great because I felt like I was
on the right track
you know if somebody was gonna buy it
you know if that interested in it and
they just never made the film because
they couldn't put together the the cast
they wanted for it but that was kind of
a Raiders of the Lost Ark thing that was
kind of cool and that that script still
has all those bridesmaid never a bride
you know it's like people are it it gets
optioned every once in a while and
better then doesn't get made
you